les 16 minutes vous écoutez réunion 1ère
et on vous en remercie l lundi politique
gaël de dantec et puis réunion 1ère
maintenant vous écoutez la première elle
vient de sortir de sa cinquième ou
sixième grève en quatre ans des grèves
d'employés municipaux qui dénonce un mal
être au travail une absence de dialogue
et de respect a dénoncé de son côté une
grève politique piloté par des opposants
qui veulent sa tête
cette grève est terminée mais les sera
de nouveau des traces sur le bilan
social de celle qui a toujours mis en
avant la démocratie locale et
participative
comment ses convictions ont-elles évolué
à l'épreuve du pouvoir qui est devenue
la militante écologiste alors de
l'aménagement du territoire des
carrières pour la nrl et de la gestion
des déchets qui est devenu l'adepte du
dépassement des partis politiques à
l'heure de la politique macro nien
vanessa miranville maire de la
possession vice président du tc au
présidente du mouvement citoyen de la
région d'action est l'invité de lundi
politique sur la première et je précise
hans dieter qu'ils peuvent nous suivre
en vidéo sur le site internet de la
première sur la chaîne youtube de la
station vanessa miranville bon soir dans
ça merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
d'abord un mot de cette tempête
tropicale modérée fakhir qui assure la
réunion cette nuit et demain la
préfecture a décidé la fermeture de tous
les établissements scolaires c'est une
bonne décision pour vous oui je pense
qu'il faut être prudent quand ce genre
de situation se produit parce que
prendre les décisions à la dernière
minute notamment le matin c'est mettre
les parents dans l'embarras ces faits
relate un point justement 16h pour le
lendemain matin
oui mais en même temps je comprends
aussi que le préfet puisse pas non plus
trop anticipé enfin là je crois qui est
que ce phénomène météorologique nous
prend un petit peu plus tous deux
surprises mais j'imagine que les parents
auront auront quand même un peu le temps
de s'organiser même si ça va être
compliqué mais la sécurité avant tout la
mairie est prête à faire face à ce genre
d'aléas climatiques arrivée au pouvoir
ses hauts il ya des choses que vous avez
particulièrement surveillé la d'ici
demain
en fait nous c'est surtout la
circulation sur les voies qu'on va
surveiller le fait que qu'il n'y a pas
d'arbres qui qui obstruent la voie et
auquel cas sinon les
les enlever vérifier de façon générale
les questions de sécurité par exemple
s'assurer qu'ils aient pas de fuite
à l'intérieur des bâtiments qui pourrait
causer un risque électrique voilà ce
genre de choses mais on est rodé
maintenant avec le nombre d'événements
qui s'est produit ces derniers temps on
vous entendu à plusieurs occasions sur
le climat pour plus précisément sur le
changement climatique et sur ses
conséquences allant peut pas dire
aujourd'hui que cet épisode est
forcément lié à un changement climatique
mondial mais ce que est ce que vous
craignez malgré tout vous les
conséquences de ce changement climatique
sur la réunion dans les années qui
viennent
ouï dire que le phénomène d'aujourd'hui
alors si jamais un phénomène celle qui
est liée au changement climatique
mais quand on regarde on voit bien que
les températures à l'île de la réunion
dans nos endroits du monde les la
sécheresse maintenant la houle l'érosion
des plages et la force d où la fréquence
des phénomènes cycloniques
voilà tout ça va dans un sens qui n'est
pas très optimiste maintenant c'est
quelque chose qu'on va sur lequel il
faut travailler à long terme il ya une
notion que j'ai découvert il ya quelques
temps et que j'aime beaucoup c'est celle
de résilience
comment on fait en sorte qu'un
territoire soit capable de s'adapter à
des changements qui peuvent être soit
très lent mais très profond soit brutaux
qu'il soit cyclonique et métérologiques
qu'ils soient sociaux qu'ils soient
économiques voilà et je pense que la
réunion vit plusieurs cyclones entre
guillemets auxquels elles doivent faire
face les ce qu'il faut développer pour
être résilient c'est la capacité à
réagir en bonne intelligence de façon
coordonnée solidaire et pouvoir
peut-être aussi s'appuyer sur nos
voisins de l'océan indien sans qui on
peut on pourra pas compter enfin on ne
pourra pas faire sans dans les années à
venir
c'est ça faire de la politique par
exemple et de la réunion est résiliente
oui oui je crois que mon sentiment c'est
que
on a plus on a perdu un grand
visionnaire en perdant messieurs paul
vergès sur l'avenir de la réunion et
notamment sur ces questions de
développement durable donc dont je
rappelle que les trois piliers sont
indissociables économique social et
environnemental
et voilà il manque peut-être cette
vision à long terme pour les vingt
cinquante prochaines années auxquels il
faut réfléchir parce que nos enfants
vivront ces moments là et si on n'y a
pas réfléchi si on les a pas préparé
ils seront plus difficiles à vivre
maintenant il faudrait effectivement une
prise de conscience globale et moi
j'aimerais qu'on sorte aussi de
l'opposition entre les politiques ou les
industriels qui disent oui non mais
c'est aux citoyens de changer ses modes
de consommation où ces comportements et
le citoyen qui dit c'est aux décideurs
de décider entre guillemets non ça c'est
pas la course à qui va commencer ou qui
va laisser la place à l'autre pour
recommencer chacun doit agir
quel que soit son rôle chacun jeu j'aime
beaucoup l'histoire du colibri à sa part
du colibri à jouer le colibri c'est ce
petit oiseau qui amène voilà une toute
petite part mais qui participent à la
grande aventure
ça peut se faire à l'échelle d'une
mairie d'une intercommunalité là où vous
êtes vous en place aujourd'hui
cette participation en fait aller à
toutes les échelles à l'échelle par
exemple d'une commune comme la nôtre
c'est de faire en sorte de faire prendre
conscience aux citoyens des enjeux nous
ont mis en place tout un tas d'actions
qui en fait sont du développement
durable parce que le développement
durable c'est assez dans le quotidien
qu'on le fait quand on fait en sorte que
les enfants par exemple mange sainement
on est dans le développement durable
parce que la santé c'est le bien le plus
précieux qu'on est tous en commun c'est
la santé quand on fait comme hier par
exemple une action de nettoyage pour la
journée de la terre basse et des enfants
qui sont éduqués à comprendre que ben
déchets ça se jette dans une poubelle et
ça se jette pas à n'importe où ou en
tout cas quand il est jeté
faut pas non plus être fataliste et 10
rebonds s'est passé pas moins de
ramasser ça ça sera à l'agent communal
non parce que en attendant à des
épidémies de dengue à cause de ces
déchets et on en revient encore à la
question de la santé enfin voilà donc on
voit bien que les toutes les questions
sont liées
et surtout que la question pour moi qui
ai que centrale autour tout ça c'est
l'éducation et les veilles de 20 pour ce
qui concerne les enfants et l'éveil des
consciences pour que ce qui concerne les
citoyens de façon générale voilà ça mur
à vue jeudi en introduction vous venez
de traverser un nouveau conflit social
au sein de votre mairie de la possession
quand est ce que vous expliquez ce
nombre important de mobilisation dans
votre commune ces dernières années je
pense que c'est la rançon de la liberté
d'expression qu'elle était donnée par
notre équipe d aya qu'à 36 heures
effectivement il n'y avait pas de
mouvements sociaux avant 2014
à la possession et pour autant on peut
pas dire qu'il y avait pas de
problématique ou pas de pas de
souffrance pas de deux conflits pas de
et c'est maintenant c'est si si les gens
se sont exprimés de cette manière assez
parce que vous leur en avait donné la
possibilité oui oui je pense que
honnêtement c'est
c'est quelque chose que les agents même
entend dire hors crise reconnaissent on
les a invités je pense qu'on a été la
première et peut-être la seule commune à
la réunion en tout cas à le faire à
faire le bilan
donc on fait traditionnellement le bilan
de mi-mandat en mode participatif donc
on a plus de 600 agents qui ont été
questionnés qui ont été entendus sur
quelles sont leurs attentes
ça n'empêche la grève non parce que bath
cette écoute elle a eu lieu au mois de
novembre et l'écoutent c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut renouveler de façon
très régulière et c'est vrai que depuis
le mois de décembre le dialogue avec les
syndicats
c'est enfin s'est détériorée parce que
moi je l'expliquent comme ça une
décision a été prise sur le plan de
titularisation qu'on est aussi la seule
commune à amener tous les ans 10 à 20
agents de la commune sont titularisés
donc c'est un plan durable pour nous et
qui valorise le mérite des agents
maintenant les personnes qui ont été
choisis ne sont pas celles qui avaient
été proposées par les syndicats ou en
tout cas pas dans le même ordre
bon voilà c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
eu du mal à accepter c'est un peu la
difficulté de la participation
c'est de bien poser le cadre est
peut-être que là effectivement on a on a
un peu pêché sur la clarté de caisse qui
est un avis consultatif et qu'est-ce qui
est une décision est la décision
clairement elle revient
jours aux élus parce que on a les mix de
la démocratie participative un moment il
ya quelques tranches oui c'est ça et
parfois certaines personnes ont du mal à
accepter que leur avis ne soit que
consultatif mais effectivement qu'il ne
soit pas complètement décisionnaire
maintenant c'est et pour certaines
décisions ça peut être ça peut être
l'enfer
on peut avoir des décisions qui soient
vraiment prises collectivement ce ça
dépend vraiment du tube du type de
décision en l'occurrence pour ce qui
concerne le plan de titularisation des
agents ou d'autres sujets qui concernent
les agents pour moi il est important que
la balle reviennent toujours dans le
camp des élus parce que il y a les
propositions de l'administration les
propositions des syndicats
et il faut bien un arbitrage final nom
qui est fait par les élus qu'est ce que
vous dites à ceux qui vous reprochent de
gouverner un peu seul ne pas écouter
ceux qui sont autour de vous de changer
les têtes quand elle vous conviennent
pas de changer plusieurs fois de
directeur général des services dans
votre cabinet ça a beaucoup bougé aussi
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à cela
ce que vous êtes en tête-- autocrates ou
est-ce que vous simplement vous voulez
avancer
quelles que soient les conséquences je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de deux
d'imagination une fantasmes autour du
fait d'avoir une mère qui est 34 ans qui
est une femme qui est la seule à voir
peut-être cet âge là et être une femme
donc forcément des comptes un jour était
un homme de 60 ans j'aurais fait
exactement les mêmes choses que ce que
je fais c'est vrai j'ai passé mon père
c'est pareil c'est pas dans toutes les
communes y compris celles qui sont
gérées par des vieux hommes c'est pas
dans toutes les communes qu'il ya autant
de turnover dans l'est dans les cabinets
ou dans la vie oui elle est servie là je
parle sur sur le ressenti que va en tout
cas ce qui peut être véhiculés sur
l'image
quand on est une jeune femme et qu'on
prend pas ses responsabilités parce que
j'en ai je suis mère donc j'ai pris un
engagement vis-à-vis de 30 mille
citoyens de faire en sorte que qu'une
certaine éthique soit respectée oui je
la fais respecter et ça ne doit pas
plaire à certains que ce soit une jeune
femme qu'il fasse maintenant sur le turn
over
clairement je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
aime les changements pour les
changements l'instabilité ou quoi que ce
soit maintenant entre la comment dire
l'immobilisme et un changement va qui
nous paraît salutaire notamment toujours
sur les questions d'éthique
oui je vais avoir tendance choisir le
changement pour pour un nouveau une
vision à plus long terme donc les
collaborateurs de cabinet qui n'ont qui
ne sont plus aujourd'hui où les élus ou
les collaborateurs administratifs qui ne
sont plus avec nous en mairie de la
possession aujourd'hui sont des
personnes qui à un moment donné non plus
fait preuve de l'honnêteté et de la
transparence de la justice de ses
valeurs éthiques qu'on cherche à
incarner voilà et ça ça n'est autant ne
pas être sur la même longueur d'onde sur
certaines idées ou ne pas avoir
complètement rempli sa mission
enfin voilà on est aussi dans la
bienveillance et dans le réajustement
c'est compliqué c'est vrai quand on est
quelqu'un qui qui a des idéaux et qui a
envie de remplir la mission que les
citoyens et qui sont exigeants et c'est
normal nous demande de remplir il ya il
ya une intention qui se crée avec
l'administration pour voir quelle est la
bonne temporalité maintenant sur les sur
les valeurs éthiques là dessus non on ne
peut pas l'air on peut pas laisser
passer ça c'est quelque chose de non
négociable vous le disiez vous êtes
aussi vue comme une jeune femme est ce
que finalement d'avoir été d'avoir eu
cette réussite électorale dans cette
position là est ce que ça a été plutôt
un atout pour affronter avec un peu de
d'inconscience et de jeunesse les
difficultés ou est-ce que ça a été un
handicap qui vous a placé par rapport à
vos éventuels interlocuteurs comme une
proie
vu comme facile je pense que ça a été
les 2 c a eu des avantages parce
qu'effectivement je parle de résilience
je développe moi même personnellement ou
avec mon équipe à la résilience on tente
des choses vraiment se mettre dans
l'état d'esprit dans lequel on est les
gens de la possession nous ont élus en
tout cas ceux qui nous ont choisis ont
géré une ville est effectivement bas on
n'a été choisi que par 56% des votants
donc on sait bien qu'il y en a qui ne
voulaient pas qu'on soit là maintenant
on doit gérer une ville en entier on va
pas couper en morceaux les choses ils
ont fait pas de clientélisme justement
maintenant ce qu'on sait pourquoi on a
été choisi c'est amener eu un renouveau
à mener de des méthodes amené delà de la
transparence et de l'efficacité dans le
service public
donc ça va plaire à ceux qui ont choisi
ça ou qu'ils ont demandé et ça va ça ne
va pas plaire forcément à tout le monde
sa a ensuite ça bouscule d habitude je
comprends que qu'un agent municipal qui
a toujours connu la même équipe
municipale les mêmes façons de
travailler et qui se retrouve à être
face à une équipe comme nous c'est
déstabilisant donc pour ça qu'on est
beaucoup dans le dialogue dans les
coudes dans aussi expliquer pourquoi on
fait les choses et je sais que beaucoup
d'agents et d'ailleurs quand on parle de
la grève je rappelle qu'il ya eu en tout
et pour tout peut-être aller 15 %
d'agents qui étaient grévistes
donc moi je veux toujours aussi la
partie pleine du verre là c'est à dire
85% des agents n'ont pas fait grève ont
été à leur poste de travail
donc ça veut dire que ils ont reconnu le
fait que effectivement ils ont été
peut-être bousculé dans leur façon de
travailler mais que la reconnaissance et
la valorisation du travail qu'ils font
parce que les citoyens sont en sont
satisfaits bah ça n'a pas de prix
être fier de son travail ça n'a pas de
prix vous aviez publiquement dit ne pas
être allé voter parce que candidat ne
vous convenait sur un des scrutins vous
l'avez parrainer la candidature de
charlotte marchandises l'élection
présidentielle comme nature citoyenne on
va dire delà de la société civile comme
on dit est ce que vous referiez est-ce
que vous quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui
sur votre conception de la démocratie
après avoir exercé quelques années à la
mairie
moi je referai des mêmes choix dans le
sens où je reste vraiment persuadé que
le système tel qu'il existait est à bout
de souffle
le système des partis avec des dogmes
avait des idées très arrêtées
en gros la droite qui s'occupe de
l'économie
la gauche du social les écologistes de
l'environnement non moi je m'occupe des
trois piliers parce que les trois
piliers forme le développement durable
et et quand je vois l'élection d'un
président comme emmanuel macron bon bah
c'est qu'il ya effectivement une vague
de fond de refonte et de deux volontés
en tout cas des citoyens de sortir de
ces schémas un peu trop trop épais
tablit qui me semble me donner raison
dans le fait d'essayer de voir plus loin
qu'est ce que la démocratie peut donner
de meilleures que ce qu'elles donnent
pour l'instant que vous étiez
écologistes vous étiez membre d'écologie
les verts candidates femmes sous les
couleurs de ce parti reviendra dans un
instant sur les questions il ya
précisément l'écologie mais pour rester
sur la question du positionnement
politique aujourd'hui vous vous
positionnerez ou sur un échiquier leur
dit pas gauche pas de droite pas
d'écologie mais quand même sous voûte
droite gauche en l'absence non sa
puissance c'est pour ça que cette
question ça fait des années qu'on me la
pose ou est ce que je me situerais sur
l'échiquier je réponds mais pourquoi
est-ce que je suis obligé de jouer aux
échecs si j'ai envie de jouer à un autre
jeu moi alors le ce que les gens ont
besoin de savoir pour qui votent
ben non en fait les gens ont besoin de
savoir alors je suis d'accord avec vous
pour qu'ils votent donc quelle est la
personne et aux quelles sont les
personnes pour qu'ils votent en termes
de d'êtres humains est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est là pour l'intérêt
général ou pour son intérêt personnel
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est là
pour général et les candidats les
personnes diabétiques sont tous là pour
l'intérêt général
un sas et la terreur voilà bien sûr non
mais bien sûr de trouver le nom dans sa
façon de
de se comporter mais l'affichage
politique en termes d'échiquier dont on
parle et qui peut éventuellement évoluer
ça donne à l'électeur une idée du
programme qui va être mise en oeuvre de
la façon dont les élus vont réagir face
à telle ou telle situation
oui mais ça n'est pas la fin ça n'est
pour moi qu'une façon très simpliste de
présenter son programme politique nous à
l'équipe que je mène à la possession qui
représente donc ces mouvements citoyens
qui s'appelle citoyens de la réunion en
action on a cinq piliers et ses cinq
piliers ils vont parler à tout le monde
c'est le pilier ans j'en ai parlé déjà
de l'éthique de la sitôt le deuxième de
la citoyenneté et trois piliers on va
dire du saas et le comment on fait les
choses et de qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
notre projet politique pour la
possession est peut-être un plus long
terme pour la réunion la nature le
bien-être et le dynamisme
en gros ce sont les trois piliers du
développement durable mais qu'on à a
traduit dans dés mon plus concret la
nature parce qu'on ne peut pas bien
vivre si on ne maintient pas un
environnement sain pour nous et pour nos
enfants
le bien-être parce que en fait ce qu'on
cherche tous c'est quoi au final si on
enlève tous les pros les pour les grands
mots politique
on veut juste être heureux heureux
individuellement et collectivement que
c'est la notion de bien-être et le
dynamisme part parce que être bien on
voit on voit tout de suite le spa le
massage zen etc mais une ville a besoin
aussi de dynamisme économique de
dynamisme associatif
bref qui est de la vie voilà la
politique menée par emmanuel macron ça
vous vend alors le ni de droite ni de
gauche
oui il ya des choses qui bougent voilà
qui me plaisent ballon dans ce chemin
dans cette façon de ne pas être dans des
dogmes pré établis dans des voies là et
dans cette façon aussi de chercher quand
même une efficacité dans la façon de
gérer des choses c'est un certain côté
droit dans ses bottes
maintenant bon sur certains autres voilà
j'aurai pas forcément les faits les
choses de la même façon dont ils n'ont
pas fait une politique de droite comme
le dit
certains nombres d'observateurs ou
d'acteurs de la vie politique
voilà moi ce qui peut ce qui me gêne le
plus profondément dans les prises de
parole du président c'est le sentiment
qu'il ya parfois du mépris pour
certaines catégories de gens moi je me
souviens notamment parce que non à la
réunion on est plus sensible à ça quand
quand il parlait des kwassa kwassa enfin
parler du mas oreo du comorien bon voilà
ces comoriens ramenés dans les bottes
voilà il ya d'autres expressions sur les
sur les fainéants bon voilà il ya des
clichés qui sont véhiculés g que j'ai du
mal à accepter d'un président qui se
doit que j'ai dit d'être le président de
tous le tout un toute une population
tout un peuple et donc pas stigmatiser
les uns et les autres plus globalement
en termes de politique économique parce
que c'est aussi là que se joue la
distinction droite gauche peut être vous
êtes d'accord avec lui sur cette idée
qu'il faut libéraliser qu'il faut
restreindre la dépense publique à
restreindre la dépense publique
oui pour moi c'est une évidence dans le
sens où on n'est plus dans une période
faste dans laquelle on peut se permettre
de dépenser de l'argent public sans son
résultats sont sans être vraiment
redevable de ce qu'ont fait donc par
exemple sur à la mairie on est en train
de créer un poste de chargé de mission
d'évaluation et d'optimisation c'est à
dire qu'on veut s'assurer que quand on a
dépensé x euros pour mener telle action
elle a touché tant de personnel a eu
tels effets concrets et mesurables et
donc bacon qu'on puisse évaluer si cette
action mérite d'être continuer ou
reproduite ci on estime que non que
l'argent n'a pas n'a pas donné les
fruits escomptés
on reverra l'action autrement où on
abandonnera cette action au profit d'une
autre
donc ça c'est clair que rationaliser
enfin moi je vois les choses
positivement c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de faire avec peu de moyens
financiers mais en même temps ça nous
oblige à être économe c'est pour ça
qu'on a nous fait en sorte d'acheter des
véhicules électriques pour avoir moins
de dépenses de carburant qu'on travaille
sur les économies d'eau et d'énergie
donc en rénovant un tiers de notre
éclairage public cette année qui va nous
faire économiser
près d'une centaine de milliers d'euros
qu'on va rénover l'éclairage des stades
sportifs de la façon d'arroser les
espaces verts ou les stades
voilà donc il ya plein de bonnes choses
qui se mettent en oeuvre maintenant il
faut être comme dans tout il ya des
limites
la libéralisation un peu oui papa trop
enfin j'aime beaucoup la théorie de la
juste mesure des danses la base des
dépenses publiques à la réunion c'est
notamment des difficultés on l'a vu au
chu sait les difficultés pour les
mairies notamment à cause de la baisse
des emplois aidés ça vous avez été en
première ligne où vous avez dit non
cette baisse des emplois aidés ce n'est
pas une bonne idée pour cent la baisse
de la dépense publique elle est bien là
aussi oui alors sur la question des
emplois aidés moi je suis effectivement
et je reste là dessus sur l'idée qu'il
ne faut pas nous enlever brutalement un
système sur lequel on sait très bien que
les collectivités de la réunion s'appuie
fortement qui 1
une façon aussi de ne pas perdre une
certaine partie de la population et de
les renvoyer vers vers une pauvreté dont
ils auront toutes les peines du monde à
sortir maintenant qu'on puisse réétudier
le système est là on a on est passé du
contrat unique d'insertion au parcours
emploi compétences la mairie ou non mais
honnêtement avec un nouveau nouvelle
façon de faire les choses moi ce que je
regrette c'est que ça a été un peu
brutal
l'arrêt du c'est lui et surtout que ça a
été avant même que on ait pu avoir les
éléments pour sur le pecs et j'en
reviens à la grève à la possession
oui on s'est retrouvé avec des agents
par exemple dans notamment dans le
scolaire parce que c'est beaucoup là que
les des emplois aidés se situe qui sont
retrouvés à être 10 à servir à manger
aux enfants dans une cantine c'est un
fait un fait réel
puis neuf huit sept six jusqu'à arriver
à 5
oui effectivement à 5 pour faire le
travail que faisait dix personnes oui
bah là il n'y arrivait plus et donc qui
se sont manifestés donc voilà on a
essayé de leur expliquer mais ça ça
n'est pas forcément du ressort de la
mairie que de ne pas pouvoir aller sur
les nouveaux emplois aidés tant que le
dispositif n'est pas annoncer clairement
maintenant il l'a été depuis maintenant
une semaine
donc ça a été au moment en fait de la
grève
qu'on a pu enfin savoir quelles étaient
les les dispositions précises notamment
de formation qu'on nous impose pour ses
parcours emploi compétences et donc on a
pu s'engager dans la signature du
protocole à recruter 20 agents
polyvalents pour les écoles de la
possession sur ces nouveaux parcours
d'insertion
donc ça se remet en place mais ça a été
un peu brutal et surtout la transition
c'est mal fait concrètement dans les
écoles de la possession le résultat ça
va être quoi en nombre de thèmes en
personnel dans les écoles vous êtes en
forte réduction par rapport à ce qu'ils
avaient des années précédentes alors on
est on a essayé de faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de diminution de plus d'une
atsem par école donc elle reste quand il
y avait six atsem
elles sont au moins encore 5 maintenant
on va en voit aussi qu'il ya un taux
d'absentéisme qui est quand même
important parce que c'est des métiers
qui sont fatigants servir les enfants à
la cantine soulever les les grosses
marmites on a des agents qui ont pour
beaucoup plus de 50 ans soulever les
enfants aussi pour les atsem et c'est
donc cet absentéisme la basse et c'est
lui qui fait que le système étant devenu
un peu juste en termes de nombre
d'agents on s'est retrouvé en difficulté
à cause de l'absentéisme donc la très
concrètement ces 26èmes ou surveillants
serveur ou agent d'entretien donc on va
recruter des gens un peu polyvalent
justement s'ajuster aux besoins de la
journée qui vont arriver dans les deux
semaines qui viennent dans les effectifs
de la ville et donc on pourra comme ça
va être plus réactifs pour gérer ces
absences
après sur les par exemple sur ce qui
concerne l'environnement et pourtant
c'est crucial les parcours emploi
compétences ne nous permettent pas de
recruter des agents sur l'environnement
sauf dans le cas particulier de la lutte
anti vectorielle
donc on va être obligé de prendre des
personnes en cdd
donc ça c'est des surcoûts pour la ville
donc c'est à l'ass et c'est un équilibre
très très très complexe à trouver entre
combien de cdd on peut prendre combien
d'emplois aidés on peut quand même
prendre mais sachant qu'il faut des
tuteurs de la formation etc
voilà mais moi je toujours suis
optimiste si
si on arrive à réussir ce pari là c'est
vraiment une nouvelle façon de créer de
l'insertion durable aussi pour ces
personnes parce que les emplois aidés
ont trop peu été utilisé comme des
variables d'ajustement pour cela il me
manque un peu de monde je veux avoir des
gens pour pas cher donc je prends des
emplois aidés là on change de logique on
est vraiment dans l'insertion des
personnes qu'est ce qu'on offre comme
avenir professionnel à ces personnes
voilà on s'inscrit là dedans et on
espère qu'on a notre petite échelle
on traite le problème du chômage à la
possession est peut-être un plus
largement après la reine pour la baisse
des dépenses publiques ça se traduit
aussi par une dotation commune notamment
il faut faire aussi bien si ce n'est
mieux avec moi alors vous avez dit tout
à l'heure vous fait la chasse aux
gaspillages il faut aussi compter sur
des augmentations d'impôts
éventuellement au mot à l'autre alors la
position c on a dû gérer en plus du
contexte global de toutes les
collectivités c'est dette
alors soit qui était réelle ou soit dans
le bâti donc 12 millions d'euros qu'on
doit rendre sur les 15
quinze années depuis 2015 donc je compte
me le 30 à la famille qui ont les doigts
c'est énorme sur mu un budget global
d'un peu plus de 50
quelques millions d'euros et on doit
aussi gérer la dette dans jeudi dans le
bâti c'est à dire que il faut savoir que
sur notre commune
en 2014 il n'y avait qu'un quart des
bâtiments dont on était sûrs qu'ils
étaient aux normes de sécurité
le trois quarts des bâtiments restants
soit n'avait jamais été vérifiées ouvert
administrativement pourtant des écoles
qui fonctionnait depuis 25 ans mais qui
avait jamais été vérifiées en termes d
alarme incendie etc
mme edwards était carrément une jugée
défavorable donc c'est donc les normes
et donc les impôts on a dû les augmenter
déjà deux fois et l'engagement qu'on a
pris ces deux c'est de faire en sorte de
ne plus les augmenter pour sur les deux
prochaines années
en espérant que la bouffée d'oxygène des
recherches de subventions qu'on est en
train de faire des ventes de certains
fonds si bas qu'ils ne servent pas la
commune et peut-être des recettes de la
carrière des lataniers si elle doit être
validée permettent voilà de retrouver un
équilibre financier
on va y venir mais d'abord une pause
musicale c'est vous vanessa miranville
qui avait choisi cette pause musicale
weekmate du dj selon un avis qui est
mort récemment à l'âge de 28 ans
l'écoutent
[Musique]
firmin tout en mai
là nous y sommes
tout y est
st
[Musique]
là bas
[Applaudissements]
baby
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
lalonde
el pais
c'est là que c'était faux airs de viol
[Musique]
est ce le cas mais fo
le
il pas
mieux
[Musique]
et
oh
oh oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dj suédois avicii qui est mort récemment
l'âge de 28 ans je le disais en
introduction pourquoi cette chanson
veulent à sa mue en ville pour rappeler
que la vie est courte
à quelle est belle qu'il faut en
profiter et que à barr moment voilà on
laisse une oeuvre comme comme ce dj on a
laissé voilà enfin il a été un peu une
étoile filante
moi j'aime bien toujours me rappeler
prendre la distance avec les choses et
regarder les défenses de loisirs entre
le moment où je n'ai le moment où je
vais partir de cette terre qu'est ce que
j'aurais laissé on a parlé tout à
l'heure vous venez vanessa miranville de
l'écologie politique est aujourd'hui sur
la table un certain nombre de dossiers
concrets qui peuvent éventuellement art
et vos anciens amis on pense à la nrl ou
transports eau déchets l'on va prendre
ces sujets un peu dedans l'ordre sur le
chantier la nouvelle route du littoral
il faut ouvrir des carrières pour
alimenter la construction de la digue et
dont éventuellement la carrière des
lataniers sur votre territoire de la
possession qu'elle le quel est
aujourd'hui votre position dit il faut y
aller il ya pas de souci a pas de doute
en fait notre position elle est claire
depuis maintenant deux ans et demi il
nous a fallu entre le moment de
l'élection et le moment de comprendre
toute la complexité de ce dossier dont
on n'avait vraiment pas pas tous les
éléments avant d'être élu le temps de
consulter à nouveau les citoyens parce
qu'il y avait une décision importante à
prendre pour la commune ils nous ont dit
à 75%
si la carrière nous nous est garanti
avec le minimum de nuisances possibles
et avec des recettes qui vont venir nous
aider énormément j'ai la question
c'était un peu ça ou les impôts oui mais
c'est la réalité
un moment donné faut aussi dire aux gens
la réalité des choses et les mettre bas
devant les décisions qu'il n'y a pas de
doutes sur l'impact écologique que ça
peut avoir sa place après il faut bien
les recettes mais non c'est pas que ça
passe après c'est que faut bien
comprendre qu'on n'est pas sur un
terrain vierge avec deux des espèces
endémique etc on est là sur un site qui
est une friche d'anciennes carrières sur
lequel les espèces invasives ont pris
complètement le pas sur sur les espèces
locales et au contraire nous notre
projet c'est pas de faire une carrière
ça c'est le projet de la région qui a
effectivement besoin d'approvisionnement
pour un chantier que dont je rappelle
qu'il est aussi d'intérêt général donc
nous notre position en tant que commune
c'est premièrement on veut contribuer à
un intérêt général dont nous mêmes on
est aux premières loges pour sur be
subir les nuisances à chaque fois que la
route du littoral est fermé les
possessionnais sont asphyxiés par la
circulation ou sont eux mêmes victimes
de cette paralysie premièrement et
deuxièmement on veut réaménager un
espace qui a été utilisée par l'homme et
des séances riches pour le pour le
rendre à la nature avec des espèces
endémiques dix mille arbres qui sont
plantés à terme et pour l'instant ça pas
commencé non parce que justement la pris
le temps de consulter les citoyens et
ensuite de faire les choses avec le
maximum de garanties donc là on en est à
la phase d'après ce que finale pour ce
qui nous concerne de choisir le carrier
donc il sera délibéré en conseil
municipal d'ici le mois prochain et qui
va ensuite permettre à ceux carrier donc
on a eu deux candidats on en choisit un
parce que sur les critères justement de
nuisance minimaliser de recettes pour
pour la commune d'aménagement le plus le
plus complet possible du site après
exploitation est donc ce carrier
déposera ensuite un dossier
environnemental sanitaire à la
préfecture qui se prononcera pas ce que
c'est bien le préfet une fine et qui
décide s'il estime que que la carrière
respecte toutes les normes et le
bien-être des citoyens riverains mais en
beauté je vous en parliez là nos jours
du littoral va pas résoudre les
embouteillages visiblement ni les
problèmes de pollution il faut
absolument développer les transports en
commun tout le monde est à peu près
d'accord sur cette idée là ça bouge pas
beaucoup et ça se passe pas très bien en
ce moment au syndicat mixte des
transports dont vous faites partie en
tant que représentant du du tc aux états
et la mairie
qu'est-ce qui se passe oui il en faut
bien comprendre que bat en tant que la
politique politicienne de des alliances
et des mealli
c'est ça qui est en jeu bah oui
malheureusement je ne suis pas
directement au syndicat mixte mais c'est
mon adjointe à l'aménagement madame
lambert et qui est aussi vice-président
transport ôter ses lauriers et voilà à
chaque fois qu'elle m'en parle d'elle et
elle est complètement désemparé de voir
à quel point les vrais enjeux qui sont
cruciaux pour nous tous réunionnais des
déplacements à la réunion sont mis en
second plan dans cette instance par
rapport à des tractations politiciennes
et enfin ça je dis clairement ça nous
donne envie de vomir nous de savoir
comment les choses se placent se passe
sur un sujet aussi important maintenant
et vous ne pouvez rien y faire ben voilà
on n'a pas la majorité ont elles
essayent de se faire entendre
elle essaye de faire entendre raison je
sais que récemment et je sais qu'il ya
une la vice présidente madame couapel
sauret qui est aussi très active sur sur
le sujet on travaille en très bonne
intelligence avec elle à la région elles
ont enfin avec les autres membres du
syndicat mixte a réussi à dire stop à
des dérives du du président du syndicat
mixte des transports et enfin peut-être
qu'une nouvelle ère s'ouvre pour sur ce
sujet là maintenant mois sur la question
transports en commun je pense que
l'avenir il est aussi dans l'innovation
dans les transports les gens ne
prendront jamais un transport en commun
si ça leur demande de mettre trois
heures de temps alors qu'en voiture il
mettait il m et 30 minutes allaient même
une heure une heure et demie on avec les
bouchons ou même le même temps parce qu
au moins dans sa voiture on et voilà on
est indépendants on peut aller là où on
veut on peut s'arrêter faire un crochet
on à sa musique etc
on a un certain confort moi je crois
vraiment à l'innovation et on est en
train de on a lancé bordant une étude au
niveau du tc haut sur le transport
aérien personnalisé aérien parce qu'on a
plus de place au sol à la réunion et
qu'on va pas exproprier bientôt chacun
sandrone on se promène dans les airs non
c'est en gros faut imaginer du câble du
transport téléphérique au câble mais
personnalisée c'est à dire un peu le
principe des voitures autonomes c'est à
dire qu'on a des réseaux et que on quand
on veut aller d'un endroit à un autre
on ne s'arrête à aucun autre endroit au
milieu et on va vraiment à la même
vitesse que qu'on irait en voiture donc
ça pour moi c'est l'avenir du transport
on est en train de lancer l'étude et
j'espère que dans quelques années ça se
concrétisera autre sujet
important la gestion des déchets didier
robert dans la région a dit qu'à
quelques semaines qu'il ne voulait plus
des uv eux c'est unité de valorisation
énergétique autres noms des
incinérateurs très critiqué par les
écologistes mais défendue par les
syndicats intercommunaux qui ont déjà
lancé leur projet il ya des gros enjeux
financiers aussi derrière financiers on
le sent bien quelle est votre position
vous un incinérateur d'anciennes enfin
l'ancienne façon de gérer les déchets
s'étaient je prends tous les toute la
poubelle grise verte bleue donc le tout
venant et je le brûle directement là on
travaille sur des projets donc unité de
valorisation énergétique qui sont quand
même différent c'est à dire qu'il ya un
tri en amont on va prendre ses poubelles
est d'abord on va en extraire ceux qui
encore recyclables on va en extraire
aussi tout ce qui est compostable ou
méthanisation tout ce qui est organique
en tout cas et on va faire en sorte de
valoriser en énergie donc tout ce qui
tout ce qui se décompose et c'est
seulement le résiduel donc du plastique
des petits morceaux de plastique de
cartons de papier qui sont souillés de
toute façon qu'on va brûler
moi j'estime que effectivement dans une
situation idéale
on ne devrait pas aller vers ces vers
l'unité de valorisation énergétique
on devrait réussir à les choisir vos
déchets les opposants